Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Two, Episode Five: local self-government in the municipalities and regions.
Democracy does not only live in Christiansborg.
Local self-government is a cornerstone of Danish democracy.
It has deep roots in history that local communities solve many of society's common tasks.
Denmark is among the countries in Europe that have placed the most tasks with local and regional government, in municipalities and regions.
The tasks of Danish municipalities in particular have grown strongly as the welfare society has developed.
Today municipalities and regions solve a wide range of the public sector's tasks.
In that way they are an important foundation for the welfare society.
Local self-government is a form of close-to-the-people democracy, a nærdemokrati.
It gives the individual citizen the opportunity to influence the conditions that are close to citizens' everyday lives.
That can be in the municipality or in the region.
It happens, among other things, through municipal and regional elections.
Alongside national democracy in the Folketing there is thus also local and regional democracy in the country's municipalities and regions.
The municipalities' right to manage their own affairs independently is in the constitution.
But there is not much else in it about the municipalities, and nothing about which tasks they should solve.
It is the Folketing that sets the framework for local self-government and decides the municipalities' tasks.
The state supervises how the municipalities solve their tasks.
The idea behind local self-government is that public tasks that affect individual citizens' daily lives should be solved as close to the citizens as possible.
This is often called the proximity principle, nærhedsprincippet.
There is also a tradition that municipalities, as far as possible, should themselves be able to decide how they will solve and finance the local tasks.
Often the municipalities get the chance to solve public tasks in the way that best suits local needs and wishes.
Municipalities also have the right to levy tax.
In that way they themselves help to raise most of the money to solve their tasks.
But there is a big difference between the populations living in the individual municipalities.
Some municipalities have many more citizens with high incomes than others, and thus a better tax base.
Other municipalities have more citizens on transfer income, for example cash benefit, unemployment benefit or early retirement pension, and thus higher expenses.
To make sure there is money for a reasonably uniform welfare society all over Denmark, there is therefore a series of municipal equalisation schemes and state grants that move a lot of money between the municipalities.
Besides this, it is the Folketing and the government that set the conditions for the municipalities' work.
And the relationship between state and municipalities is sometimes marked by conflict.
The Folketing and the government are interested in the municipalities following national policy, and in all municipalities in the country giving citizens roughly the same offers and conditions.
In contrast, some municipalities feel from time to time that the state interferes too much in local self-government.
They think the municipalities are deprived of the opportunity to decide for themselves how they want to solve the tasks.
Danish local government is constantly developing.
On the first of January, 2007, a larger structural reform came into force.
From that day, 271 municipalities were merged into 98, and the former 14 counties, amter, were replaced by 5 regions.
The distribution of tasks between the state, the municipalities and the regions was also changed.
The state and the municipalities can themselves levy taxes.
But unlike the old counties, the regions do not have the possibility of levying tax themselves, but instead receive money to cover their expenses from the state and the municipalities.
Denmark thus consists of 98 municipalities and is divided into five regions.
Region Hovedstaden, the Capital Region, with 29 municipalities.
Region Sjælland, Zealand, with 17 municipalities.
Region Syddanmark, Southern Denmark, with 22 municipalities.
Region Midtjylland, Central Denmark, with 19 municipalities.
And Region Nordjylland, North Denmark, with 11 municipalities.
Region Hovedstaden and Region Sjælland will be merged on the first of January, 2027.
The new, merged region is to be called Region Østdanmark, Eastern Denmark.
Now, who leads them?
Danish municipalities are led by elected municipal councils, kommunalbestyrelser, which are often called city councils, byråd.
The chair of the municipal council is called the mayor, borgmester, and is elected by the municipal council right after the municipal election.
In the same way, each region is led by a regional council, a regionsråd, which elects a chair itself.
Members of both municipal councils and regional councils are elected for four years at a time.
The election is held all over the country every four years in November, and the municipalities and regions cannot choose to hold elections at other times.
Every adult citizen has the right to take part in municipal and regional elections.
You just have to be eighteen years old and have a permanent residence in the municipality or region.
So you do not need to have Danish citizenship to take part in municipal and regional elections.
It is enough that you are either a citizen of another EU country, Iceland or Norway, or that you have lived permanently in Denmark without interruption for the last four years before election day.
All citizens who have the right to vote in municipal and regional elections can, as a main rule, also stand as candidates in these elections.
Most nationwide political parties also stand in the local elections in municipalities and regions, but other parties and groups can also stand.
Local questions often make local citizens' groups stand on their own candidate lists, the so-called local lists, lokallister.
The local lists often fight for quite specific local political goals.
The latest election to municipal councils and regional councils was held on the eighteenth of November, 2025.
As a result of this election, the mayoral posts in the country's municipalities are distributed among the different nationwide parties like this: Venstre 42, the Social Democrats 26, the Conservative People's Party 20, SF 5, Liberal Alliance 2 and the Social Liberal Party 1.
These parties thus hold the mayoral post in 96 of the country's 98 municipalities.
In addition, Tønder Municipality has a mayor from the Schleswig Party, Slesvigsk Parti, which represents the German minority in South Jutland, while Lolland Municipality has a mayor from the local party Din Stemme, Your Voice.
As a result of the election to the four regional councils, three of the chairs come from Venstre and one from the Social Democrats.
Finally, the organisations.
The country's regions and municipalities have many tasks and interests in common.
They therefore work closely together through Danske Regioner, Danish Regions, and KL, Kommunernes Landsforening, Local Government Denmark.
The two organisations' overall goals are to strengthen local self-government in the regions and municipalities.
For example, KL represents the municipalities in negotiations with the government about the municipalities' finances and about bills.
Here is your recap for Episode Five.
Local self-government is a cornerstone of Danish democracy, and the right of municipalities to manage their own affairs is in the constitution.
The idea is the proximity principle: tasks should be solved as close to citizens as possible.
Municipalities can levy tax; regions cannot.
On the first of January, 2007, 271 municipalities became 98, and 14 counties became 5 regions.
The five regions are the Capital Region with 29 municipalities, Zealand with 17, Southern Denmark with 22, Central Denmark with 19 and North Denmark with 11.
Capital and Zealand merge on the first of January, 2027, into Region Østdanmark.
Councils are elected for four years, in November.
You can vote in local elections from eighteen, if you live permanently in the municipality and are either a Danish citizen, a citizen of an EU country, Iceland or Norway, or have lived in Denmark for the last four years.
The last election was on the eighteenth of November, 2025.
Mayors: Venstre 42, Social Democrats 26, Conservatives 20, SF 5, Liberal Alliance 2, Social Liberal Party 1, plus one from the Schleswig Party and one from Din Stemme.
KL and Danske Regioner represent municipalities and regions.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
How many municipalities are there in Denmark?
Option A: 275.
Option B: 179.
Option C: 98.
[DA] Hvor mange kommuner er der i Danmark?  A: 275  |  B: 179  |  C: 98
The answer is C: 98.
It appeared in the November 2020 and June 2022 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: 98
Question 2.
When were the regions created?
Option A: 2007.
Option B: 1968.
Option C: 1929.
[DA] Hvornår blev regionerne oprettet?  A: 2007  |  B: 1968  |  C: 1929
The answer is A: 2007.
It appeared in the November 2020 and November 2021 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: 2007
Question 3.
How often are municipal elections held?
Option A: Every third year.
Option B: Every fourth year.
Option C: Every fifth year.
[DA] Hvor ofte afholdes der kommunalvalg?  A: Hvert 3. år  |  B: Hvert 4. år  |  C: Hvert 5. år
The answer is B: Every fourth year.
It appeared in the June 2021, November 2022 and November 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Hvert 4. år
Question 4.
Can the regions levy taxes?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Kan regionerne opkræve skatter?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is B: No.
It appeared in the May 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Nej
Question 5.
Which authorities levy taxes?
Option A: The state and the regions.
Option B: The state and the municipalities.
Option C: The regions and the municipalities.
[DA] Hvilke myndigheder udskriver skatter?  A: Staten og regionerne  |  B: Staten og kommunerne  |  C: Regionerne og kommunerne
The answer is B: The state and the municipalities.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Staten og kommunerne
Question 6.
Who do municipal councils consist of?
Option A: Civil servants appointed by the government.
Option B: Politicians elected by the municipality's population.
Option C: Representatives chosen by the local business and association life.
[DA] Hvem består kommunalbestyrelser af?  A: Embedsmænd udpeget af regeringen  |  B: Politikere valgt af kommunens befolkning  |  C: Repræsentanter udvalgt af det lokale erhvervs- og foreningsliv
The answer is B: Politicians elected by the municipality's population.
It appeared in the June 2026 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Politikere valgt af kommunens befolkning
That's the end of this part.
Well done.